l'or va s'entendre sur quelque chose ici
c'est des jets d'eau des jeux de rôles
que j'ai en voyant partir seul jour 6 de
la campagne électorale où l'art délicat
d'attirer des citoyens pour avoir une
conversation petite balade à laurier
québec
mais françois legault n'agit pas
toujours comme un aimant mais pourquoi
venir ici à part pour l'air conditionné
il va s'écouler 12 minutes entre le
moment où ces trois candidats s'installe
et celui où manon massé va arriver alors
il faut meubler
on parle de la poutine de philippe
couillard et on chuchote une idée ça
tombe bien on s'en occupe on parle de la
nouvelle sur québec solidaire sortie le
matin et la candidate dans verdun
s'interroge tournée des radios de québec
pour jean françois lisée au micro de luc
lavoie qu'ils tentent d'imiter ce
sympathique monsieur lisez va donner un
petit peu d'intérêt marc labrèche et
meilleur je pense que si mathieu prost
radio-canada syrie sur le monde qui
demande un salaire minimum de 15
[Musique]